thanks jillian there's a holiday for
everything and cheese pizza is one of
those things that is truly deserving of
theirs national cheese pizza is this
sunday and helping us celebrate early
and giving us a lesson on how to create
the perfect pizza pie is maria and gigi
bonano from bonanno's new york pizzeria
welcome lady thank you this is very
exciting national cheese pizza day how
are we celebrating at bananas well at
our downtown summerlin location we are
doing two for one slices and pies and
that's going to be this sunday september
5th for national cheese pizza day and
for national pepperoni pizza day we're
doing the same thing okay so i have
heard so many good things about the
amazing crust at bonannos what makes
your crust so good and can you give us a
little demonstration on how you create
this amazing crust of course so gigi can
give you a little bit of the
demonstration of how she shapes okay
show me how you do this and i'll answer
why it's so special so
um not only because it's our family's
pizzeria but because we get our flour
imported from italy as well as our
tomatoes so the flour is a specialty
flour our caputo super americana
and that's a flower that only a few
pizzerias have been able to utilize in
the u.s
and our tomatoes are extra special
because they are from a region in naples
where the soil is enriched with
volcanic ash from mount vesuvius so it
makes them like super tasty and
delicious oh my gosh she's giving me a
how can i do it one hand one hand one
hand backwards to the right it's an art
form for sure
wow look at it look at you go you make
all these pizzas there gigi yup all day
she made me
tell me about this boardwalk test that
you guys do at bonanno's this is this is
a test of a true pizza right yes so um
obviously we're a family business um we
started here in las vegas 30 years ago
my dad has started our company and he is
very intense with his pizza so when we
were kids on the boardwalk we would walk
along the boardwalk and if the pizza
would flop over he'd say oh doesn't pass
the board walk test so we wanted to
create a pizza that people could walk
around the las vegas strip with and it
stands up you don't have to worry about
toppings falling off for anything gives
you that nice crispy bite and you guys
have like nine locations with more to
come look at some of these amazing
delicacies you got everything from your
traditional pizza to your garlic knots
all sorts of great stuff thank you
ladies for showing us
gigi's is way better than mine
send it back to you
it's all about the food today i'm so
excited mercedes saved me a bite of that
pizza